there's no doubt that the weight of the
studies and there have been many studies
indicate the benefit of wearing masks
I'm going to refer to one of them you've
heard about it before put that on the
screen its conclusions said Tom
Jefferson the Oxford epidemiologist who
is the lead author were unambiguous
there is just no evidence that they
masks make any difference well what
about the studies that initially
persuaded policy makers to impose mask
mandates they were convinced by
non-randomized studies flawed
observational studies yeah but there are
other studies Michael that show at an
individual level for individual but when
you talk about as an individual basis of
someone protecting themselves or
protecting themselves from spreading it
to others there's no doubt that there
are many studies that show that there is
an advantage individual level for an
individual that's so interesting because
you fouchy were the guy pushing for
lockdowns and school closures which
weren't at the individual level